existen 170 venados en una reserva la
población de venados se incrementa en
una tasa de 30% cada año escribe la
función de dt que describe la población
de venados en la reserva dentro de años
pensemos en ello y como siempre los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo por su cuenta
veamos a que es igual p de 0 p de 0 es
la población inicial de venados y eso lo
sabemos aquí nos dicen que hay 170
venados en la reserva la población en el
tiempo cero ahora a que será igual de
uno pues será la población después de un
año y aquí nos dicen que la población de
venados se incrementa en una tasa de 30%
cada año así que tendremos nuestros 170
más 30 por ciento por 170 esto es igual
a 170 más punto 3 por ciento 70 30 por
ciento en decimales es igual a punto 3
30 centésimos o tres décimos o podemos
escribir esto como si factor hizo este
170 tendremos 170 por 1 + 0.3 que es lo
mismo que 170 por 1.3 y es importante
observar esto detalladamente ya que lo
veremos con frecuencia cuando estamos
incrementando cierta cantidad en cierta
proporción esto es algo que veremos con
mucha frecuencia
en las funciones exponenciales cuando
crecemos un 30% significa que mantenemos
nuestro 100% original y a este le
agregamos un 30 por ciento por lo que
multiplicamos nuestra cantidad original
por un 130 por ciento y un 130 por
ciento es lo mismo que tener un 1.3
así que si crecemos un 30 por ciento
crecemos tres décimas por lo que
multiplicaremos nuestra cantidad
original por 1.3 sigamos usando esta
idea para continuar ahora cuál será
nuestra población en el segundo año
bueno comenzamos este segundo año con la
población que teníamos al terminar el
primer año es el primer año es decir 170
por 1.3 y durante este año vamos a
crecer otro 30% que es multiplicar esto
por 1.3 nuevamente o podemos decir que
esto es igual a 170 por 1.3 al cuadrado
y creo que ya se están dando cuenta
hacia dónde vamos si queremos escribir
una p
en general tendremos la cantidad con la
que comenzamos 170 y después lo vamos a
multiplicar por 1.3 elevado a la
cantidad de años que hayan pasado a la
potencia t ya que por cada año crecemos
30% que es matemáticamente equivalente a
multiplicar por 1.3 así que después de
100 años la población será igual a 170
por 1.3 elevado a la potencia 100